i want to start today with the haitian
immigration crisis uh this is
potentially one of the first major joe
biden
tests
that is sort of going aimlessly and
contributing to joe biden's declining
approval rating we talked about joe
biden needs a big accomplishment
to stem the decline in his approval
rating
the situation with haitian immigrants
does not seem to be helping so we're
going to go through it and i think you
know it's
there's this unfortunate thing where
every time i say hey guys is biden
dropping the ball here people angrily
email me and they say david have you
become some kind of right-wing trumpist
or whatever
presidents mishandle things and it
doesn't mean that i would prefer donald
trump to be president of the united
states just sometimes
presidents don't immediately or at all
handle situations correctly and i think
this is one of those situations where
due to its complexity and due to
conflicting messaging from the current
administration uh it is hurting joe
biden and we can talk about to what
degree that's fair so let's start with
some of the latest news here
reuters reporting angry scenes at haiti
airport add to biden pressure over
expulsions and we'll talk about what
that means in a second
angry scenes broke out at haiti's main
airport on tuesday among migrants set
home from a squalid texas border camp as
u.s president joe biden faced mounting
pressure to stop an expulsion's policy
the u.n refugee refugee chief said it
may be illegal nearly ten thousand
migrants mainly haitian remain in
worsening conditions in the impromptu
camp that sprung up under a bridge
spanning the as it's called in the in
the us the rio grande from the texas
town del rio to mexico to that acuna in
recent days u.s authorities have removed
at least 4 000 people from the site for
processing and detention centers
some 523 haitians have been deported to
their homeland on four flights with
repatriation set to continue on a
regular basis according to dhs
returnees reacted angrily as they
stepped off flights at port-au-prince
airport after spending thousands of
dollars on arduous voyages from the
troubled caribbean nation via south
america hoping for a better life in the
united states on tuesday they found
themselves back where they started a
group of men in white t-shirts rushed
back toward the plane after they
disembarked with one man attempting to
get back on board witnesses said
the migrants broke into a restricted
area of the airport as they attempted to
recover passports and personal
belongings ground staff closed the door
of the plane
before the man could scale the steps
back in tempers ran high exacerbated by
the news the haitian government had
accepted the deportations so there's um
there's an an okay article in politico
outlining the potentially problematic
future of this for joe biden now before
we look at the article i think it's
important to mention
part of the problem here
is that this is a very complicated
situation and you simultaneously have
gensake saying the treatment of the
migrants is unacceptable
um
and you have deportations but they're
saying well the people being deported
are basically just the men but the women
and children are staying and
conservatives are angry either way so
i'm not pretending that there is
objectively a correct solution here that
would absolve joe biden of any drag on
his approval
but we can still acknowledge that this
is causing a problem for joe biden the
politico article
says biden slips into political
quicksand amid haitian migrant buildup
the articles by natasha karecki and
laura baron lopez and the article says
the mass of thousands of haitians at the
u.s southern border has put the biden
administration in the exact place it's
tried to avoid knee-deep in immigration
politics i think that's completely
accurate
in the past 24 hours the white house has
responded to images and videos of
aggressive tactics used by border patrol
to corral migrants by supporting an
internal investigation into the matter
what it hasn't done yet is figure out a
solution to the crowding and sanitary
issues arising in what's become a
makeshift encampment or stop its policy
of deporting migrants upon arrival
that's left the president and his team
with few supporters and allies and
we can talk about what should be done
while also recognizing that
in terms of biden taking heat there's
almost really nothing he could do right
you criticize the treatment of the
migrants by border patrol and the right
says oh look you're on the side of the
illegals
rather than of law enforcement and then
you do deportations and the left says
well but if we're acknowledging that
these people aren't being treated
correctly then you just send them out
back to the situation that is a disaster
in their country uh
that that's also bad and that's inhumane
and you don't improve the situation at
the encampment and that's inhumane but
if you do improve it then the right says
you're coddling criminals as they like
to say so
i get that no matter what there would be
criticism and yet we can still talk
about what is the correct path forward
which we which we will do
the article in politico goes on to say a
coalition of more than 38 civil rights
and immigrant advocacy leaders sent the
white house a letter calling on biden to
stop expulsion some of whom arrived to
the border community after fleeing
violent and natural violence and natural
disaster in their home country the
letter marks a final straw said nana
giamfi executive director of the black
alliance for just immigration
um
described the moment as an inflection
point for biden's commitment to a humane
immigration policy
members of the president's own party
including chuck schumer echoed the call
to end expulsions increasingly they did
so while directing their ire at the
white house for its handling of the
situation
12 house dems uh will hold a press
conference
calling on biden to halt deportations so
what is it that should be done here uh
it's not totally clear but it's causing
a problem for joe biden whose approval
rating has now hit a new low of 43 as of
yesterday
kamala harris down to 49
uh this is the lowest approval rating
that joe biden has had and this does not
yet fully account for what's going on at
the border with the haitian migrants
this uh poll ended on september 17th and
it has joe biden down to a presidency
low of 43 percent now it is typical
that presidents see approval
decline
throughout their presidency as we've
talked about before many people just as
soon as the president does one thing
they don't like
they say i no longer approve
and it's often difficult to change that
we've seen that with many presidents
at the same time there is a question
here about whether joe biden drops into
the 30s
and my expectation my prediction was as
we saw the approval rating start to go
down around the afghanistan situation
which i i agree with leaving afghanistan
as just as a reminder if you've not seen
those segments my thought was it'll get
down into the low 40s before it might
turn around and start going up i don't
think the situation uh in del rio is uh
going to help so what should happen you
know it seems as though
a sort of balanced approach here would
be
um
provide
better conditions and sanitation figure
out a way to do it the right will say
you're being soft but remember the
right's been saying that since january
22nd
before joe biden changed anything about
what was being done at the border
the right was already saying joe biden
is being soft
so either way they're going to say that
materially improve the sanitation
situation at the border must do there's
food shortages etc
uh do
some kind of a temporary pause on the
expulsions now the right will say these
people are here illegally so of course
you're going to deport them at and at a
certain point this is going to have to
be adjudicated in a more serious way but
the problem is if you don't put a pause
here you don't even allow the
opportunity to say
is there a valid case for asylum here
now many of us would say obviously there
is look at the situation in haiti
it's a legal question but if you just
immediately do the expulsions you don't
even allow the opportunity to do that
you're not going to please the right
that's the reality but at this point
nobody's happy with how this is being
handled and i think the the major
criticism is it seems aimless where it's
not really clear
what is even the goal
uh down there and so we will see if in
the i think by monday there has to be
some clear messaging and we may even get
it today from jen saki who's going to be
by the time you listen or watch today
the press briefing will likely already
have been held
now i i want to talk about kind of the
sideshow there there's always with every
real story and the situation in del rio
texas with the haitian migrants is a
very real story
joe biden is not uh putting forth a sort
of coherent package of what it is that
should happen
and that needs to be done
but there's always a side show and the
sideshow here is fox news reporter peter
ducey with a bizarre gotcha attempt with
jen saki the white house press secretary
yesterday focusing on
has joe biden been to the border in his
life that's the question this is just so
pathetic and the problem with this is
that it generates the idea
that these are sort of like valid
questions and the right way to hold the
administration accountable this is just
gutter trash okay let's take a look at
the video has president biden ever been
to the southern border
in his life yes i will have to get look
back in my history books and check the
times he's been to the southern we have
been looking all morning and we cannot
find any record of him visiting the
border as president vice president
senator or even as a concerned citizen
why would that be
i can check and see when the last time
or when he may have been but but tell me
more about why you're asking because
this is a president who makes a point
when there are disasters in this country
like a wildfire or
a hurricane to go and see for himself
firsthand
what the needs are of the local
community so that he can have informed
pov to make policy why doesn't he do
that why doesn't he go down to del rio
texas and see what's going on well first
of all peter i think the situation at
the border is the result of a broken
system and the president certainly
relies on his experience so whether it
was the work he did to address root
causes as vice president
his efforts when he was in the senate to
support comprehensive immigration reform
a steps that at a time or being done and
work toward in a bipartisan way
something that
certainly we think should be the case
today so you know the answer from
gensake is okay
but
there are real questions here as we
discussed in the last segment uh you're
opposed to the treatment of the migrants
but at the same time you're not really
improving the sanitation and food
situation but at the same time these are
at least for now people who are here
illegally but at the same time even
though you want to be more humane you're
you know
expelling people without any real uh
analysis of the situation and it's not
really clear what solution you're
proposing and biden's approval is
declining there's a real situation here
that could develop into a very
significant drag for joe biden
but whether biden has been to the border
is really completely irrelevant and it
also bears mentioning i guess
that even on just going to a location
when you're a president
doesn't necessarily really do much i
mean remember when after the uh
hurricanes and i think it was um i think
it was 2017
when donald trump went to puerto rico oh
wow he went wow that's great
he shot rolls of paper towels like
basketballs
and appeared completely insensitive and
arguably made things worse
by just bringing his whole entourage and
and and team and you know the entire
apparatus that travels with the
president to a place that was trying to
recover still didn't have power back on
in many places etc so merely going is no
big victory and unfortunately
this counts as like valid journalism
among many on the right this is they see
peter ducey
uh ask his questions with his you know
up speak and bizarre delivery
um and they say wow
he really exposed this administration no
he really didn't
uh and particularly in this situation
this is not a natural you know a natural
disaster where you go and tour damage
and and console victims uh this is a
this is an immigration situation with
complex legal circumstances
what would even be the point of joe
biden going down there like aside from
whether in general a president needs to
go somewhere in order to properly deal
with the situation in this particular
case it seems joe biden going down there
would it would it at minimum add nothing
and that worse possibly even make the
situation more complicated so it's
another failed gotcha but sadly in this
country given the lack of you know uh um
sort of awareness that so many people
have about what are the important
political questions and how do we figure
out problems in in society and in
government
um this is this is considered really
powerful journalism and that's probably
uh why fox news keeps peter ducey in the
white house press briefing room what do
you think needs to happen
um on the border with this particular
situation find me on twitter deepakman
and let me know
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
let's get right into some interesting
posts from the david pakman show
subreddit remember that you can
participate in the discussions at
davidpakman.com slash reddit nearly 35
000 of our viewers and listeners are
subscribed free to the subreddit
davidpakman.com slash reddit a couple of
interesting posts i spotted
william mcadoo posted this morning
or no uh yesterday david was right about
tulsi gabbard being a phony and links to
a piece done by our friends over at the
young turks
about tulsi gabbard defending drone
usage to tucker carlson you know i have
to admit
i completely
forgot about tulsi gabbard it's actually
crazy how you know she was polling one
two three percent
there was a movement that was very
strongly behind her
um that wouldn't allow any criticism of
tulsi gabbard and said she is really the
progressive in all this different stuff
she clearly was not she just disappeared
left congress etc and then now all of a
sudden she's back and she's criticizing
joe biden and she's defending drones and
she's doing all sorts of very strange
things
i my advice is
just don't worry about tulsi gabbard uh
i i find her i couldn't find her less
relevant truly and it's crazy oh
actually someone even posted this to the
subreddit they said it's crazy because
biden is literally more progressive than
she is there there's no question about
it there was nothing uh the the entire
tulsi thing was just a scam and i'm glad
that there are more people now
understanding
that they may have fallen for a scam but
it's a very good thing that tulsi has
basically disappeared other than i guess
appearing on fox news and tweeting
another post from uh user king versing
torix i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
which says covid has killed about as
many americans as the 1918 to 1919
flu
with the
additional caveat that many people died
from secondary bacterial infections
during the 1918 flu pandemic because uh
that was um that was the the situation
back then and that when you account for
that in a sense uh covet itself has
killed more
um and yet we continue to see a large
portion of this population in the united
states that just doesn't want to take it
seriously even to this day and you know
at some point they're going to be bailed
out that's the crazy thing like
most people will survive assuming covet
doesn't you know
mutate into something far more deadly
which is not expected to happen
most people will survive
and no matter when it happens they will
say we told you so we told you we never
had to actually do anything but yeah the
flu comparison number is now uh becoming
a
relevant and much discussed topic
and then lastly
um a critique of this uh deferral that's
taking place to the senate
parliamentarian
with a post called the most powerful
office in the nation
the parliamentarian
is exerting its power again writing
senators chuck schumer and dick durbin
are beating the drums again that the
almighty nameless overlord simply
referred to as the parliamentarian is
putting a stop to all the good things
the lovable democrats want to do there's
absolutely nothing they can do it's like
trying to beat thanos
with all the infinity stones okay
seriously i can't believe they're trying
this boldface lie again
it's very clearly just an excuse to
renege on their promise
uh david sirota posted on twitter not
only can chuck schumer replace the
parliamentarian kamala harris can
overrule a parliamentarian daily poster
was one of the only outlets to report
this back during the 15 minimum wage
fight because apparently nobody is
allowed to mention this fact yeah i uh
i i i think the only way to say it is
i'm pretty sick of the parliamentarian
stuff um the parliamentarian can be
overruled the parliamentarian can be
replaced and the idea that this amount
of power is being given
to an unelected individual to set the
agenda of what is even going to be
discussed and voted on uh in the senate
i
my preference would be i know the right
will say oh it's authoritative look at
these democrats that are authoritarian
my preference would be
overrule and replace as necessary
uh get these things debated
get republicans on the record actually
opposing them on the merits if that's
what they want to do
and let's hold people accountable and
actually try to push for some of this
stuff and of course the cynical reaction
would be
you know this is democrats finding a way
to not have to have the debates
about some of these things that will
split the party and there's probably
validity to that uh but i'm disgusted
with the parliamentarian stuff and i
agree listen
on 15 minimum wage i get the math of it
right even if you overrule the
parliamentarian and you put min 15
minimum wage in the covet bill
it doesn't pass i get that and that's a
specific situation
it's now just being used as an umbrella
when you you already may not have all
democrats supporting the agenda so put
this stuff in and let's actually get it
to the floor and debate this stuff
that's my view
if you disagree with me let me know join
the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit we now have video
of former breitbart propagandist and
former trump advisor steve bannon who at
one point was participating in meetings
with the national security council
the backwards nature of how these
absolutely
horrible people 50 to 60 years from now
when this era is studied
and people like steve bannon
jared kushner and stephen miller
are part of the discussion of history of
the people that had influence at this
point in time let's hope the future
forgives us uh steve bannon now has
admitted
um that he helped plan
the january 6 trump rally that
ultimately led to the trump riots
in order to kill the biden presidency in
the crib that's the phrase he used we're
going to look at a clip momentarily
trump white house chief strategist steve
bannon said he spoke with trump ahead of
his rally on 6 january
discussing how to quote kill the biden
presidency in the crib shortly before a
pro-trump mob laid siege to the capitol
to stop the certification of president
joe biden's election victory
during a broadcast on real america's
voice mr bannon played a clip from msnbc
of washington post reporters robert
costa and robert woodward speaking about
the events that led up to the capital
riot let's pick this up at exactly that
point in the broadcast talking to you
that night steve bannon on the phone
he's telling steve bannon over at the
willard hotel we need to kill the biden
presidency in the crib
that was the phrase based on our
reporting in that conversation
yeah because it is legitimacy let's look
at the economist poll the economist not
the war room not revolver the economist
42
of the american people 42
percent of the american people think
that biden did not win the presidency
legitimately
it killed itself
that's why this debt ceiling fight the
cr fight so so important that's why
getting and exposing to the world the
mogadishu
situation in del rio texas particularly
for all the hard-working hispanic
blue-collar hispanics in this country
american citizens let me talk about that
briefly that's actually we could do a
half hour just on that the the um the
hard-working
working-class blue-collar hispanic
american citizens
there is so
steve bannon is a is a horrible
reactionary but steve bannon is part of
a slice of the right that recognizes
particularly in states like texas
you're going to need to appeal to
hispanic voters
if you want to continue winning those
states and in fact trump did okay
with hispanic voters if you look at
florida i know cubans are particularly
right-wing hispanic voters
but he did okay in florida actually
he won florida thanks in part to
um a pretty strong level of support from
from cuban-american floridians steve
bannon understands that and that's why
now you're starting to see people like
bannon
um placate
and sort of pay lip service to
working class american hispanics who are
american citizens that is
it you know it's dangerous in the sense
that if they succeed
uh it will allow them to hold some of
these states longer than than all else
being equal they otherwise might be able
to so we're going to come back to that
but that's not what you might be
wondering why why all of a sudden is
steve bannon talking about you know
appealing to hispanic voters it's
because he is part of a slice that
recognizes what's going on and that they
need those vote voters in order to keep
winning places like florida texas uh
maybe even other states
just let this go what this illegitimate
regime is doing
it killed itself okay but we told you
from the very beginning just expose it
just expose it
never back down never give up and this
thing will implode and we'll see in
doing so we will save our country so uh
not denying there that he was involved
and talking to trump about that they had
this plan
he is basically saying here the plan was
justified the plan was justified because
a lot of americans never believed or
don't believe or still don't believe or
were convinced that joe biden didn't
actually win the election the whole
point here was to expose this and to
expose it early and to expose it from uh
day one so
that is steve bannon um not denying that
saying yeah we were justified in
organizing that rally the rally which
eventually led of course to the uh to
the riots and by the way consider the
double standard right there's the double
standard of
we absolutely had to plan that rally
because joe biden either stole the
election or was already setting us up
for a disaster or whatever and at the
same time the rioters were were really
antifa they were they weren't really
trumpists but we did plan we planned the
rally but the rioters were fake and we
were justified in one but we had
absolutely nothing to do with the other
come on guys come on
last thing
kill it in the crib
is weird phraseology for a supposedly
anti-abortion group of people there's
something a little bit odd about that
phrase but maybe we won't get into that
right now we'll have more coverage and
clips from this very strange steve
bannon show
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show on instagram
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow it's great
to have back on the program lee mcintyre
who's a research fellow at the center
for philosophy and history of science at
boston university also author of the
book how to talk to a science denier
conversations with flat earthers climate
deniers and others who defy reason it's
great to have you back on leigh
thank you for having me back so when you
started writing this book
it was before kovid but we ended up with
this incredible situation where we are
now
being held back in fact in our battle
against this pandemic in part because of
exactly the type of science denial that
you write about in the book and you end
up actually including covet specifically
in a chapter
what happened was i got the contract to
write the book just uh in mid-march
20 2020 just as kovit was
lockdowns were happening and of course
i'd planned the book started the
research for it even before that and i
told my editor i wanted to save the last
chapter for covet denial and he said
well you know there is no cover denial
well either way
and
so i watched coveted and i'll be born in
real time
you know after having studied science
denial all these years and thinking
about climate denial and anti-vaxx and
just watching it fulfill exactly the
steps that the other science deniers had
laid out and it was all completely
predictable
so i mean where to even start with this
i guess the the first thing would be
maybe let's start a little bit with the
vaccine issue you know before kovid you
actually had some bipartisanship on
vaccine conspiracy theories you had
groups of people on the left who were
skeptical of vaccines because of their
skepticism of big pharma and you had
people on the right who were skeptical
of some vaccines because of their
skepticism of anything that is
government authorized of the fda etc and
there was a little bit of overlap and
you'd have these measles clusters in
some places that are left-wing and some
places that are right-wing when it comes
to covid and the covet vaccine it seems
to have dramatically shifted to what we
would consider the political right is
that perception true and and why is that
you got it exactly right uh before covid
andy vax was
more a bipartisan or i should say
nonpartisan because you know you had
liberals and conservatives um and yet in
some ways what happened with uh kovid is
that the anti-vaxx movement got taken
over or let me put it this way this was
the kind of thing that the anti-vaxxers
were were prepared for and it did get
polarized of course you know trump and
the
republican party are part of why it got
so polarized
and then it has ended up where it is
some science denial is politically
polarized
climate change uh covered um some of it
is not but that was one thing that we
also saw which was the anti-vax movement
morph into the anti-covid vaccine uh
movement i'm sure there are still uh
folks who are anti-vaxxers in general
who are uh you know on the on the left
sure but you're correct that it has been
taken over now by the right wing
what line of argument is most effective
thinking not generally now just in terms
of getting people to re-examine
anti-science beliefs but
just to get people vaccinated what are
the lines of argument that you believe
would be most effective or is it really
not about argument and it's just about
requirements
well
you you you frame that just right it's
not about argument
um but it can't just be about mandates
and requirements either okay i think
there has to be something i mean
mandates i think are are part of it
because this kind of denial is is
killing us
but i think one thing that i recommend
in the book is that we make some efforts
to actually begin to talk to one another
and it may seem that that's impossible
because
uh facts don't matter in this debate you
know how how much debate does there have
to be um the problem is that this like
other forms of science denial
is not just about doubt it's about
distrust
and that wall of distrust has grown when
we don't talk to one another and so i
think the best possible thing we could
do to get people to take the covet
vaccine
is to reach out to the people who
already love and trust us and talk to
them
those are sometimes the hardest
conversations
but i think that we have to have to do
it
we have to be respectful we have to be
calm we have to be empathetic
and actually listen to what people's
concerns are there's a hell of a lot of
disinformation out there right now
and if it helps think of
cova deniers or the vaccine hesitant
however you want to think of them as
victims
they're afraid
and they're all of this disinformation
surrounding them they don't know what to
do
so
just to be uh somebody who listens uh
you know to that family member or friend
asks them why they believe this why they
trust this source not that that can
actually work wonders
yeah i mean
what you're saying makes perfect sense
and yet i'm imagining even some of the
conversations i've had with viewers
sometimes who
say well listen um
the new one is hundreds of thousands of
people have died from the vaccine okay
so that that's one that on august 24th a
very popular facebook video started
spreading and you say to some of these
folks okay where did you get that idea
well i got it from this video okay well
what data is the video citing and
they'll say just just look at the
submissions to the veyers system the
v-a-e-r-s system and then you say well
but listen have you visited the website
anybody can submit anything nothing on
that system is verified there's a
campaign to submit false reports to that
and then they say now i i i believe that
it's real you've not proven that the
reports are false so then where do you
go with that
uh i think you went a good way down the
road of where uh where you go with that
um when people insist on proof i think
it's important to point out that that's
an unreasonable standard you don't ask
for that standard for i mean you could
but it's unreasonable to ask for it for
anything else they haven't proven that
aspirin is uh safe you know 100
safe i mean that's just not how science
works science is about building up
evidence and warrant for your beliefs
but it's not deductive logic it's not
euclidean geometry you can't prove that
that something is safe and and and i
think it's also important to point out
to folks that just as you did about the
veris system that it's it's being gamed
they're thinking that these are good
faith reports you know anecdotal reports
some of those reports are coming in from
trolls they're coming in from folks who
are trying to get other people to
believe false things and
of course this isn't going to convince
anybody but it's nonetheless important
to know
that the other day i read in a
politifact that the appointer institute
which is the fact-checking organization
had found that
zero
zero uh uh cases of people dying from
the covet uh vaccines so there was not
one credible case now that doesn't mean
that it couldn't happen it doesn't mean
that it hasn't happened it just means
that there is not evidence that it has
happened
but you know compare that to the
ridiculous
numbers sorry that are being proposed
you know i've heard people say you know
that they're ten thousand uh or more or
a hundred thousand more where are the
why aren't aren't the media reporting
this then why are you know you only
finding it in the vera system or you
know you're hearing a rumor from your
cousin
they're
these would be reported
but they're not and it's yes it's fake
i mean the problem with that of course
is and you know we've we've done a bunch
of interviews on conspiracism and
conspiratorial thinking
um if they find evidence for their uh
conspiracy theory no matter how flaky it
becomes supportive of their conspiracy
theory
if they find an absence of evidence like
the fact that there is not media
reporting it's part of the cover-up and
it becomes evidence of the conspiracy
theory if there is
you know contradictory evidence then
that evidence has been concocted and is
not trustworthy and i just don't know
how we really deal with that on a
wholesale basis your ideas make perfect
sense empathy listening one-on-one it
feels very
sort of retail and i don't know that it
deals with the wholesale problem of the
millions that fall for this stuff
um
you bring up a good point here
there are
once you're talking to people who have
fallen for it it's in some sense too
late oh it is
it's already spread right right so i
mean we should be talking more about
who's behind the disinformation campaign
and how the this information gets
amplified
uh and i i can say a little bit more
about that if you want to yeah please i
mean what but once that's out there in
the world then you know you do have to
talk to the to the deniers and let's
start with that
um
you it's it's
generally a good idea not to get into a
factual debate with them because their
position is not really based on facts in
the first place and right jonathan swift
said you you can't reason somebody out
of something they didn't reason
themselves into in the first place
but notice a couple of the things that
you've mentioned
they have to do with logic they have to
do with evidence they have to do with
the way that people are reasoning on the
basis of evidence and so to point out
you know to a conspiracy theorist
well what could convince you that this
conspiracy theory is wrong then right
because if there's evidence for it you
accept it if there's no evidence you
think that that counts for it too i mean
how how do you know that this is the
case you know so
you know talking and there's in fact
good empirical evidence now there was a
study in the nature human behavior in
2019
which showed that something called
technique rebuttal can work against
science deniers all science deniers
engage in the same form of toxic
reasoning they cherry pick facts they
rely on conspiracy theories they engage
in illogical reasoning they rely on fake
experts and they think science has to be
perfect and once you know that blueprint
you can call them out on it
in a respectful way
but you know you don't have to get into
a uh factual debate you know where what
often happens with me is somebody will
send me an email and say well you know
here are 20 things that you need to read
immediately um you know and i
i don't i don't i'm not going to get
into that debate with them because you
know why are they trying to convince me
if they have the evidence they should be
trying to you know convince the cdc or
the other scientists now they'd say
that's part of a conspiracy what i
always do is i punt to the idea of well
let's talk about your reasoning let's
talk about how
you're you've come to the conclusions
you've come to why do you trust this
person you know why do you trust this
video that you saw etc etc
and the interesting part here is
to a group of conspiracy theorists
raising the issue of trust
that might work for you
right and the the other thing that
sometimes i mean this is when you get a
couple of these conspiracy theorists
together oftentimes their justification
they might end up with the same belief
but with very different justifications
and getting them to realize that they
don't even agree with each other about
what even is the proof like flat earth
is a classic one where the explanations
for why people come to believe it are
often conflict with each other and it
can get pretty interesting when you
actually get them saying well here's how
i came to the conclusion versus how you
did and they conflict very much
and yet they all ultimately agree with
one another on the conclusion right
because of what they have in common
which is distrust
they have distrust of scientists
distrust to the media distrust of
you know government
and so
here's the thing that i found in in this
research that i've been doing
if it were just about doubt
then evidence would help because you can
overcome doubt with evidence scientists
do it all the time
but distrust
cannot be overcome with evidence alone
distrust has to be managed by
having the person grow to trust you and
how do you do that you do that through
trying to build a personal relationship
with them through engagement now that is
a very frustrating uncomfortable and
difficult thing to do and most people
would rather walk away then do that
the reason i wrote the book is to make
it clear to people that if you do that
you're being a denier
because there is scientific evidence
which shows that every day ordinary
citizens like you and me can go out and
talk to science deniers use technique
rebuttal and maybe change their minds so
why aren't we doing more of that now
that's not sufficient you know there
there again there's a problem of the
creation of disinformation as
amplification we've got to do something
about both of those things
but what can we do every day just right
where we sit
we can talk to people who disagree with
us
engage your cousin engage your uncle at
thanksgiving talk to them about why
you know what are your reasons for not
getting the covet vaccine we can ask
them we can have a conversation about
that one of the last things i wanted to
talk about there seems to be this meta
problem
where particularly in the trump era
there is now not even i i don't know if
agreement is the right term but there is
a lack of understanding as to what
counts as an empirical claim and what is
just an opinion
and we are very frequently seeing for
example
when people are presented with just the
the the empirical reality of for example
whether it was really trumpists who did
the trump riots and they come back and
say listen it i i just
my that's fine you can believe that my
belief is that it was antifa and they
they think that what these issues are
issues of opinion when they're really
just issues of fact is that a broader
educational problem or how where does
that stem from
the problem this is why we need to take
science denial seriously because it's
not only about covid and about climate
change but it has metastasized now to
reality denial what i'd call post-truth
that stopped the steal the idea that the
january 6 was antifa this is a denialist
campaign it's a classic denialist
campaign that follows the same five
tropes of reasoning about conspiracy
theories etc that i gave you before
right that's why we have to get ahead of
this now you ask exactly the right
question where does this come from
and the answer is
it comes from the folks who are creating
the disinformation
we've got to stop thinking of science
denial as an accident or a mistake it's
a lie
someone is intentionally creating
disinformation not misinformation but
disinformation now to ask who
uh quite a bit of it is from foreign
intelligence services for instance in
russia
people may not believe that but it is
out there i didn't break into cia
headquarters to get that information it
was out there in major media in about
march or april it was about a one or two
day story but um there was a terrific
article in the new york times about a
year and a half ago called putin's long
war against american science there are
russian troll farms that manufacture
disinformation about
health issues uh about gmos about about
covet about anti-vaxx because they want
to undermine
the united states they want us to be at
one another's throats fighting about
what we're fighting about they've done a
great job of it right here's the
interesting next step though
though that disinformation is then
picked up and amplified on social media
and it doesn't take that many people to
do it uh there was a story in npr the
other day that the um
65
of the uh anti-vaxx propaganda on
twitter was due to 12 people right i
mean so
this is why we've got to realize we're
in an information war
and in an information you know as a
country
uh and in an information war you have to
figure out who's uh spreading the
propaganda and how it's being propagated
so i think that in the wall street
journal series this week i think makes a
pretty good case that facebook is not
doing a very good job self-regulating
they know how polarizing their platform
is they they understand that they're
helping the spread of disinformation
they're not doing much about it
the book is of course how to talk to a
science denier conversations with flat
earthers climate deniers and others who
defy reason we've been speaking with the
book's author lee mcintyre lee always
great having you on i appreciate your
time thank you so much for having me
back
subscribe to our youtube channel at
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show watch the
full hour-long show individual clips all
of our interviews and everything else
from the show and when you subscribe
make sure to click that bell button to
be notified about every new video
i'm going to give you guys a tour of the
last 24 hours of republicans on the
floor of the house and the floor of the
senate okay
when i've been saying
say when i've been reminding people
that the right has abandoned policy that
this new sort of breed of trumpist
doesn't even pretend to be about
anything other than pr and tweeting and
memes
i didn't literally expect that there
would be a day where they just hold up
printouts of memes on the floor of the
house and even on the floor of the
senate but that day came yesterday
and we're going to look at some examples
here and we're going to talk about
the real underlying problem here because
this is really a societal problem if
this stuff didn't work to get people
elected if it was laughable wait hold on
you just do tweets and memes obviously
we're not voting for you if that was the
case
then this stuff wouldn't exist because
they never would have made it to the
floor of the house what am i talking
about well let's just start with
marjorie taylor green
marjorie taylor green spent the day
yesterday on the floor of the house
with oversized printouts of different
memes
and
talking about how the memes are real and
this is completely beyond parody so
here's the first one this is a meme
where um there is a uh
i can't i'm describing memes for the
audio audience this one is a two-frame
meme that says let's see who this really
is and it's a prisoner
with a blindfold that says green new
deal on it and then when they remove the
blindfold i guess that's the hammer and
sickle of communist china you know i
need to check know your meme i guess
here's marjorie taylor green this is a
simple meme that you would find on the
internet but this meme is very real the
green new deal surprise
is serves china and china only you can
go ahead and put number one up
so today talking about the green new
deal and the all-out war on the men okay
they're they're doing
you know i would respect a sort of like
powerpoint presentation
if it was substantive like when senators
and members of congress pull out charts
and graphs of different data and they
understand it and they understand how
these you know different economic
elements relate to all other that's fine
they're they're putting up pictures it's
like this is the house equivalent of
trump's uh daily presidential daily
briefing
instead of being many pages they cut it
down to a couple pages and he still
wouldn't read it so they cut it down to
one page
and then they cut it down to a page half
of which was like a chart and then two
or three bullet points this is the how
the the floor of the house version of
that uh marjorie taylor green continued
then here is the next meme
here is one
um
which says i own joe biden
and now i own afghanistan's lithium
deposits and the idea is that it's china
loving the fact that biden got out of
afghanistan i guess marjorie taylor
green wanted to stay there even though
trump wanted to leave and she's a
trumpet because it's all incoherent
i find it pretty shocking that people
actually think that members of congress
and their legislation is actually going
to control the earth's temperature or
temperature
um so this is now going on about climate
change and again it's just marjorie
taylor green on the floor of the house
with memes here's a bonus meme from the
senate this was also yesterday this is
senator joni ernst also kind of of the
same vein
slightly less cartoonish than marjorie
taylor green
but almost as ignorant she also puts up
a meme and she says this is a popular
meme i've actually never seen this one
this one seems to be
um
they're almost like are those go fish
cards or uno cards
that say uh trillion and 1.9 trillion
for the stimulus bill 1.2 trillion i
guess it's about making fun of
democratic spending or something that
this i'm sorry and then she puts up
another one that uh
it's just all it's all pathetic mario
reminds me of this popular meme
of a guy playing uno okay it was uno and
it's just about democratic spending
guys it's it's not an exaggeration
republicans in the house and senate
yesterday
their arguments and their presentations
are they put up printouts of memes
and they say see guys this is what
democrats are doing these are their
critiques
um
this is the bigger issue
of the memification of the republican
party we've talked about increasingly
absent of policy they are literally
showing memes it proves that point now
just a couple other examples just of the
low level of discourse these aren't
memes but this is just the idiocy that
we've come to to see on a regular basis
here's congressman mike lee he is taking
issue with the fact that
when the cdc
counts causes of death they don't
include abortion as a cause of death
why would that be well because abortion
is not considered death
like dying from covet
that's that's why okay here's mike lee
states and i just want to go over this
because i think sometimes we become
disillusioned with which what is
actually happening oh yeah the national
center for health statistics at the
centers for disease control and
prevention reports on the leading causes
of death in the united states but does
not include abortion among their list of
causes of death
right
that's his gripe so this is again
another one of these issues of
why are we even talking about this and
people watch it and think this is valid
political discourse and when we've
talked about
the sequelae of trumpism
whether trump goes away comes back or
doesn't
one of the things we have to contend
with and we're seeing it i mean these
are examples of it are that the
coarsening of discourse under donald
trump
has made it so that these types of
presentations on the floors of the house
and senate memes and why does an
abortion count as a cause of death all
of this stuff
it's considered valid politicking for
many republicans even though you and i
hopefully see it for what it is
which is just meaningless garbage uh
just one more example here here's
trumpian congresswoman lauren beaubert
she's making the point
that victims of rape
need access to guns not access to
abortions
okay lie number two
rape victims need abortions wrong they
need love they need support
they need safety and healing they needed
a glock 19 when it happened
right um and this of course the context
is
the situation with the extremely
restrictive abortion law
passed in texas and the debate that's
been generated over that how do we
recover from this and what i mean by
that is how do you turn around
after five years of the political
discourse being
your fake news
where is my african-american
um
what about injecting the hitting the
body with light and heat
uh and all of these all these different
pocahontas and all of this stuff it's
now just the republican party that's
what it is and
one of the things would be if both sides
were having substantive
adult discussions about important issues
and then we focus on the substance we
don't even have that because the right
is holding up memes on the floor of the
house of representatives and the senate
and talking about abortion should be
listed as a cause of death and this type
of thing i don't know how we turn it
around and uh you know hopefully to some
degree our conversation with lee
mcintyre was informative in terms of how
to de-cultify
but this is going to be a real real big
uphill battle want to just not spend a
lot of time on this but i do want to
show you one other clip a bunch of
people wrote in asking me to talk about
this one a former trump national
security advisor michael flynn uh
suggests that there is going to be sort
of like um secret vaccination done of
people by putting the vaccine in salad
dressing he said he heard that our
friend john amato over at crooks and
liars wrote this up michael flynn is
insane says vaccine is in salad dressing
michael flynn's latest crazy deep state
spiking your salad dressing with covet
vaccine this was on
i don't even know what show this was on
uh it looks to be some kind of like
bogus medical and
financial consultation type show the ads
on the screen say uh something about
protect your health with heard help from
sherwood dot tv
and mian md vladimir zelenkommd
protect your wealth with help from
andrew zorkini
um
i don't even know where these where do
they even find these shows i don't know
but here is michael flynn talking about
i guess some kind of deep state putting
vaccine vaccines in salad dressing
does drinking the vaccine even do the
same thing as injecting it it all sounds
very stupid but here's michael flynn and
you'll notice so remember
former national security adviser michael
flynn this was the top national security
official in the country for a short
period of time he's also wearing a shirt
that has his own name on it it says
flynn it's weird it's real i mean i
gotta put you know somebody sent me a
thing this morning where they're talking
about putting the vaccine into salad
dressing or salads have you seen this
yes have you seen this i mean it's and
i'm thinking to myself
this is the bizarro world right this is
definitely the bizarre world so there's
the seriousness of what this what this
professional realized he was doing wrong
and he and he's now you know he's found
a new way and then there's the there's
this the laughability
on the other extreme that people are i
mean these people are seriously thinking
about how to impose their will on us uh
in our society and it's and it's
a choice yeah so there is no plan to put
the vaccine into salad dressing uh but
also yeah
i mean i don't i don't know that this is
really even relevant but
the people we would need to trick into
taking the vaccine
are probably more likely to have it in a
hot dog than in a salad if you
understand what i'm saying so like if
this was your approach i'd be looking at
maybe
injecting the vaccine into a frankfurter
uh rather rather than mixing it into
salad dressing it just might take i
think the folks are more likely to reach
for the dog than the salad but that's
probably probably a different issue
there is no such plan of course and it's
completely absurd and who even watches
these shows like there's a lot of these
shows that are either
religiously oriented financial advice
or religiously oriented medical advice
or just quackery
and they seem to get donations i don't
know who is watching and who would who
would be watching in a serious way like
we monitor these shows
in a sort of satirical sense like like
the horror of it
but somebody must be contributing to
this stuff and also
if they get michael flynn on maybe we
can get michael flynn on right i mean
these shows don't seem to have much of
an audience maybe michael flynn would be
willing to appear with me i would be
glad to speak to him i think that would
be absolutely great we have a voicemail
number that you can call any time of day
that number is 219 to david p
here's a caller wondering about whether
i'll be dipping my toes further into
financial youtube take a listen to this
i noticed hold on a second let's play it
from the beginning please having meet
kevin on your
hey david huge fan of the show i noticed
that you've been having meet kevin on
your show a couple times recently and
i've actually gotten some of my
financial friends to get into your show
because of me kevin
being on your show so i was wondering if
you were gonna
possibly have like graham stefan or
anyone else in the
quote unquote
financial youtube community thank you
i would be glad to interview graham
stefan i think he's doing
uh interesting stuff on on youtube as
many of you know
my formal training
is really in finance and you know my my
master's degree my mba my concentration
was financial planning it's an area of
personal interest i always hesitate to
to give advice and i try to make clear
whenever we talk about personal finance
i'm not giving advice on the show but if
there were to be like imagine that there
was no more political david pakman show
or that i started a second project it
would almost certainly be in the finance
space so yeah i would be very interested
in speaking with graham stefan or being
on with him
and uh talking about the
sort of overlap between personal finance
and politics and there there really is a
lot there
um
not sure if people in my audience would
be interested but maybe there's a new
audience to be found there all right on
today's bonus show mitch mcconnell and
the republican party are saying we can't
play games we can't play games with the
country's economic situation or finances
or the debt ceiling or whatever
meanwhile
they are playing games with the debt
ceiling so we're going to talk about
that incredible hypocrisy even though
we're talking mostly about beto o'rourke
running against greg abbott in texas
matthew mcconaughey according to polling
might be a viable candidate the actor
matthew mcconaughey what we will talk
about
is beto the right choice and then we
will also talk about mcdonald's phasing
out those plastic toys from happy meals
because they want to be more green
when was the last time i was at
mcdonald's i will reveal it on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com and get
instant access to the members only bonus
show we will see you then
you